dans ce document de dix pages signée
christophe castaner le gouvernement
demande aux préfets d'attribuer une
nuance politique seulement aux communes
de plus de 9000 habitants une
manipulation pour de nombreux élus cette
circulaire est insupportable tout
simplement parce qu'elles excluent 54%
des électeurs
96% des communes en particulier les
communes rurales du résultat c'est à
dire que monsieur castaner qui est censé
garantir la véracité des élections est
un train de truquer les élections
jusqu'ici ce système s'applique est à
toutes les communes de plus de 2000
habitants
dorénavant le calcul des scores
nationaux en fonction des appartenances
politiques ne prendra plus en compte que
4 % des localités françaises et moins de
la moitié des électeurs français
cette décision répond à une demande des
maires des petites communes qui ne se
reconnaissaient pas dans ce système
d'étiquettes imposé sans leur avis du
point de vue de l'opposition c'est un
moyen de compenser le manque
d'implantation locale de la majorité
présidentielle on va retrouver aggloméré
notamment autour de l'éthique est en
marche
un certain nombre de listes qui sont
juste des listes soutenues par en marche
qui sont des listes de divers centres on
va dire avec des élus pas forcément
encartés en marque et du coup ça a
confié naturellement leur score le
deuxième phénomène c'est que ça va
gonfler naturellement le score dans
l'art aussi d'un certain nombre d'autres
partis politiques parce qu'il ne
présente pas de liste dans les petites
communes de moins de 2000 habitants donc
donc comme c'était plutôt des électorats
on va dire urbain et bien ça va
mécaniquement gonfler le score
dans le détail les préfère le choix
entre une vingtaine de nuances
regroupées en six grandes familles
classique de l'extrême gauche à
l'extrême droite
à noter la création d'une nuance divers
centres pour la majorité présidentielle
ainsi qu'une nuance gilet jaune afin que
ce mouvement soit suivie lors des
prochaines élections précise la
circulaire
plus surprenant même l'opposition de
droite est vent debout contre cette
mesure
y compris du côté des sages il faut
qu'on fasse attention à jouer avec tout
ça il ne faut pas dénaturer l'élection
municipale
il faut pas non plus dénaturer ce que
souhaitent et décident les élus de
déclarer je pense notamment dans les
communes inférieures à 9000 habitants et
je dois dire que j'ai attiré l'attention
solennellement du premier ministre je
pense que cette circulaire cette
circulaire pas conforme aux valeurs
démocratiques qui sont les nôtres et que
cette circulaire nécessite d'être soit
réexaminée soient soumises à l'avis du
conseil d'état
plus d'un an après la crise des gilets
jaunes les élections municipales montre
une fois de plus le fossé entre élites
nationales et france des territoires
[Musique]